das ist einfach unglaublich vor den
menschenmassen und das geht ganz so
friedlich war weil es wirklich tolle
stimmung und was die typen da aufführen
mit den mitteln des vorlesens
das beste was ich machen konnte ich habe
zwar immer mehr neue weiter pflegen auf
jeden fall sein thema licht raum wunsch
die italiener waren einfach super
außer den am besten freund die
segelflieger mit der kunde seine
wiedergeburt hat es war durch die air
show als solches ist im plan
wir konnten alle programme fliegen die
der einsatz am boden ist reibungslos
abgelaufen und was mich persönlich freut
wir konnten die begeisterung der
österreicher und unserer nachbarn
erwecken es sind so viele personen hier
wie noch nie
das ist zumindest mein eindruck der
fliegerhorst zeltweg ist der größte in
österreich und der platz ist uns heute
fast so ein geworden
wir haben ein jahr gearbeitet hart
gearbeitet und waren dann alles aufgeht
dann sagen wir natürlich hilfe